-More Olympics after this.
-The Samson Galaxy S22 Ultra.
With video quality like this,
you can star in your own movies.
[ Echoing ]
Star in your own movies.
-Let's see who Lady Luck
is smiling upon tonight,
shall we?
-Three of a kind.
-Straight.
-Impressive.
But it looks like somebody
forgot to flush.
[ Suspenseful music plays ]
-Alright, boys,
we're halfway down the ladder.
So it's time to dust off
those mittens
and grease the goose,
'cause it ain't over
until the ham hits the mustard!
Now, let's go!
[ Applause ]
-Yeah!
♪♪
-Call me Captain Owl.
-Who?
-Exactly.
♪♪
-Jimmy!
What are you doing?
-[ Snort ]
I was just dreaming about a...
phone.
-Okay.
-The Samson...
With video quality like this,
you can star in your own movies.